bonjour curieuses et curieux bienvenue
dans ce deuxième mini est de sciences
toujours depuis chez moi mais ce n'est
pas ça qui va m'empêcher de prendre
quelques minutes pour vous parler de
science et comme vous allez le voir pour
vous permettre de vous envoler un peu
allez c'est parti
elle avait compris aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de drones ces petits engins
qui sont de plus en plus présent dans
nos vie y compris sous les arbres de
noël et qui nous permettent de prendre
un peu de hauteur pour faire de
magnifiques images
le problème c'est que c'est une
hécatombe en drones laisser entre les
mains d'un oncle inexpérimentées a une
durée de vie de l'ordre de 10 minutes au
mieux mes tontons j'avais dit la manette
vers le bas c'est pas compliqué le bas
c'est pour éviter ce genre de
mésaventure que des chercheurs
grenoblois tentent de rendre les drones
plus facile à manier plus sûr et même à
terme autonome c'est-à-dire capable par
exemple de nous livrer des colis sans
être directement piloté par quelqu'un
mais pour ça il faut que les drones soit
capable de se déplacer sans se perdre et
surtout sans percuter tous ceux qu'il
croise
contrairement aux drones de tonton donc
alors comment on fait eh bien on a
surtout eu recours aux mathématiques
les chercheurs développent des
algorithmes permettant aux drones
d'identifier les obstacles et de les
éviter le plus rapidement possible
[Musique]
pour cela les drones sont équipées de
caméras produisant une image
stéréoscopique
c'est à dire réalisées par deux capteurs
filmant la même scène à partir de deux
points différents et grâce à cette image
on arrive à avoir de la profondeur et
estimer la distance aux obstacles
ensuite on planifie la navigation du
drone d'un point a à un point b en
choisissant la trajectoire qui est la
meilleure par rapport à notre objectif
aller le plus vite possible vous choisir
la sécurité en passant plus loin des
obstacles par exemple finalement cela va
dépendre de ce qu'on a à transporter non
tonton je m'en fous que tu développes le
protocole de trajectoire sécurisé tu
n'utilises pas le drone pour transporter
la boîte zf et pour effectuer un maximum
de tests affiner les algorithmes et
optimiser les trajectoires
les chercheurs ont créé des simulateurs
virtuels pour drones l'avantagé c'est
que ça permet d'obtenir des statistiques
en simulant très grand nombre d'heures
de vol et deux parcours différents ce
qui serait quasiment impossible dans le
monde réel
à moins de posséder la flotte de drones
de star wars
[Musique]
non désolé vous a trompé d'un dress et
ensuite on met les drones en situation
sur un parcours bien réelle en labo pour
vérifier que ça marche aussi bien en
vrai et tout ça peut avoir des
applications qui vont bien au-delà de la
simple livraison de colis
les drones autonome pourrait être utile
pour repérer des parasites dans les
cultures par exemple ou encore pour
inspecter des ponts des centrales
nucléaires à la recherche de fissures et
un jour on pourra même transporter des
personnes grâce à des flottilles de
quelques drones capables de coopérer
voilà qui serait drôlement bien voilà
c'est tout pour ce mini est si ça vous a
intéressé vous pouvez aller voir le
reportage complet sur la chaîne du cnrs
je vous mets le lien de la vidéo et je
vous dis à très bientôt n'oubliez pas de
cliquer partager et vous abonner
ce serait dans hautement bien
[Musique]